Okay, homework 5 should be pretty straightforward.
I'd like your blog to output JSON instead of HTML, or rather in addition to HTML
when the URL ends with .json.
Let's see how this looks in real life.
Here is the blog online and showing the 10 most recent entries.
If I were to add .json to this URL and load this URL, I would get a wall of text.
You can see in here there is some JSON.
It's a list of dictionaries, and each of these dictionaries is one entry.
We'll look at the JSON for one entry so it's a little more clear.
If we were to go to blog entry 1002, which just is this short little entry, add JSON to this.
We do that and it returns just the dictionary.
The key is "content" equals "what a great body," "created" equals this date,
"last_modified" equals this date, and "subject" equals "what a great title."
We'll be looking for content and subject in your response.
You should try to also include the dates.
Keep in mind that this date is not built into the JSON library in Python.
You're going to have to actually encode this yourself.
Remember when we talked about that strftime function in one of the previous homeworks?
Well, that's a good use of the strftime function to create this little date stream.
Remember that JSON data types don't include dates.
They just include integers, floats, strings, booleans, and a null.
You'll have to figure that out.
I'd like you to have .json on both the permalink URL for the blog entry,
and on the entire blog itself.
Of course, you should also have new post continue to work.
If we were to enter a new post in here and submit this,
if we were to go to the JSON for this post, we would see the JSON representation.
Here is our JSON. One last thing I'd like to point out to you.
If I were to open up our little debugger in Chrome here and reload this page,
if we were to inspect this request,
the response has a content type of application/json_charset=utf-8.
It's important to get the content type right here.
We're not sending HTML anymore. We're sending JSON.
This is the appropriate content type to use when you're sending JSON.
Make sure you set this header as well.
When you have all that working enter your URL here.